happy to habitat hoobat house gomez my
spirit paw welcome back to Walking Dead
Season 2 episode 3 part 3 yes
nailed it no wait yes that was right you
[ __ ] it who cares let's keep playing
those are sweet eyes apples a girl you
make sure you tell me the truth when
you're sitting where you are and you
won't end up over in that chair what
happens in that chair you might not
believe this after what happened earlier
but I liked Reggie he was a funny guy he
kept things light you need folks like
that it's easy to let depression sink in
during times like this but he was weak
and I don't mean just cuz he was mean
that wasn't his problem he was weak of
will weak of character no he wasn't
[ __ ] yeah that around here not anymore
now with what we got at stake he didn't
deserve that even if he messed up he
didn't deserve to die yeah oh he
certainly did you see Reggie put us at
risk with his incompetence he's had a
string of screw-ups lately killing one
in order to save many as part of
survival it's one of the tough decisions
that a weaker person could make it's why
it falls to people like us to lead them
to safety
mmm do you understand no I really know
is different I do but they are weak and
we are strong that's why it's our
responsibility to Shepherd the flock to
keep them safe I don't know what you
want to eat you to follow not nothing I
don't know what the [ __ ] to say tonight
and we're more alike I don't like any of
the options there's no way you could
have lasted this long otherwise I
realized it back in that cabin you were
scared but you look me straight in the
eye kept your nerve
that's what we need if we're gonna get
through this the next generation has to
be stronger than the last to lead us out
of this kids like you raised the right
way the way my child to be raised it
ain't this herd that keeps me up at
night
we can handle that it's not knowing if I
got anyone to hand all this off to but I
ain't worried about that anymore
what if it's not yours yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
well even if that was true it's mine now
oh right no you there yeah I'm here the
loading bay doors jacked should I really
not the [ __ ] out of it how bad is it
rails are tweaked so I won't shut all
the way I don't think it's an emergency
or anything but it's something Stan
should take a look at what he can I'll
get him on it out that [ __ ] idiot
hurt on its way and he puts a goddamn
ding in my door go on back out to the
yard it's almost suppertime
well that was quick well I guess we did
a lot of work actually and I think about
it
forgot about that [ __ ] Sarah
I really don't like where this is going
guys we all know this morning I don't
know what that son of a [ __ ] is gonna
do next so you want to ring the dinner
bell for a herd of walkers to show up
how is that better cuz this place will
be [ __ ] chaos when that thing hits no
one will be paying any attention to us
and that's when we go it's our opening
we just got to figure out a way to drawn
to us your friend here wants to get us
killed by lurkers before bill can do it
yeah what is it with you that's what it
sounds like to me you know that's not
what he's saying but it does sound
danger this [ __ ] is all dangerous
maybe Luke could help us he wanted us a
town outside he wants a radio to help
keep an eye on the guards thank you
that's the plan I vote for you know
about Luke he flagged us down when Troy
wasn't looking told us his plan men
should he talk to you if Luke can tell
us what's going on with the cards we can
use that to pick a good time to escape
that seems reasonable
who knows when that'll be there was a
girl back at Crawford that used church
bells to send walkers all over the city
we just need something really loud the
PA system Carver is always using is
quite loud there's some speakers outside
the building pointed toward the parking
lot I saw him when we were walking out
to the work Troy's always standing next
to one of them
I saw the controls they're in Carver's
office mm-hmm she's right it's all
controlled in bills office there's a
switch in there that'll turn them on how
do you know that I used to make a lot of
the announcements back in the day I had
it flipped on once luckily there wasn't
much around at the time to hear it it
was plenty loud though that's perfect we
just gotta get into his office why
didn't you say something sooner cuz it
doesn't change anything
this isn't a discussion about how to do
it it's a discussion about whether it's
stupid and it's still stupid the
sensible thing is to get Luke the radio
and wait for an opening you're real
difficult to deal with sometimes no
that's all right I don't like to hurt
ident either we should get the radio to
Luke it doesn't hurt to have more
information I agree
fine fine we can do that but the herd is
still what's gonna get us out of here
maybe Luke can tell us where it's
hitting from
okay so we get that turn radio he keeps
us posted on the herds movement we fire
up the PA thing and bring the walkers to
roll over this place and then what get
some guns and shoot our way out I don't
know whatever we can we improvise and
that's not a plan you don't plan to
improvise yeah but your problem is you
don't think this stuff through if the
end of the plan is just a stroll through
a herd of Walker's then you should know
from the jump there's no way it's ever
going to work
yeah Kenneth King [ __ ] crazy I do it
all the time why you hear you saying
it's just some crap ha ha ha ha ha what
do you mean exactly when you cover
yourself in their smell grab the Walker
oh yeah I can't tell you from one of
them now I don't know who's crazier
trust me I've walked through herds
before it works you just have to keep
calm and make sure you're good and
covered you seem to know what you're
talking about
this is nuts yeah we did that right now
yeah what it's how we got out of the
marsh house Lee covered me and we walked
right through oh yeah really holy [ __ ]
I'm Goodwin Lee all right what are we
waiting for
let's get that stupid radio we still
have to find a way to get in the
stockroom I got a plan for that too come
on kid gonna need your help
oh really the kid gets to help out and
well what the [ __ ] here the hell'd she
come from so uh well I don't want to
talk yet we just need to use the winch
she can just climb up from there then
just drop into one of the skylights over
the stockroom
there are shelves and stuff for you to
land on so you probably won't fall to
your death oh great that thing breaks
all the time unless something's changed
it won't support much weight well
climbing isn't we much come on up and
Adam don't push her Kenny
she's our best bet it seems pretty
flimsy clam it seems pretty flimsy yeah
he's playing yeah I agree with that
clam it's you or nobody so you're
nominated we got to get that rope down
Mike you want to boost her up guess I
don't have a choice huh
don't let go I got you what I don't like
this really don't like this oh Jesus so
this cab seems to be the one in 400 days
still see if you remember try to hurry
all right I think it is I don't think
they're the sharpest cars in the world
but then no idiots either they see you
not in your bunk
we're all done [ __ ] he's coming better
you think I gotta let you go I can't
stand here grab something nah come on
all right
nice good job claim not see we don't
need you oh [ __ ] we're in trouble yeah
goddamn we're always in trouble there's
all this [ __ ] happening you're never
safe we do have a spiky sweater though
jacket whatever
don't shake [ __ ] Alexei's [ __ ]
ironically so it's okay it's okay
they must know by now that oh okay
there's gonna be two or three thousand
of them out there so why am I going in
here can't see them all but I see the
Duster it's locked
[ __ ] what about how many there are we
sure let's look down here really quick
how can I be a la chic Ross what the
[ __ ] I hope a bad fire do we get
anything good here no he's in there you
think we're ready to study I don't know
bill mix we are well bill knows [ __ ] we
thought the same thing Lister
we learned a lot at last time is it
enough though we'll find out if they
turn this way
how about we kill bill yeah get it yeah
sorry okay um tippity-tap tippity-tap
give it a tap
they were tap i'ma be a well pad here we
go yeah the edge that's nice
well what the [ __ ] I clicked everything
what the [ __ ] do you want from me I must
have missed something I guess we can go
this way run Clemmy Color Run climb a
clue huh
rank lemma clue you don't have any shoes
go sorry here we go baby they wanted to
trick you
Oh clickonce I love clickonce
they're the best who's that
don't trust her
Oh a lot of wakey tanki's crazy about
Richie huh yeah okay no yep
go on ah I was wondering if you pop know
maybe spit it out hey
yeah spit it out hanky who I don't think
no I'm gonna when I'm back in huh you
don't know you I don't know
oh [ __ ] sorry no [ __ ]
you think we're ready I think so the
homestead at least not sure about the
expansion they're out there just moaning
that's what they do
striving crazy is really unnerving I
know what you mean
figure we be used to it by now I want to
figure that never got used to a light
buzzing or anything all different human
beings walking around I'll give you that
one
so what are you doing tomorrow bill
wants me to start getting this bay door
fixed and while you're down there yep
what happened to it again Troy backed
into it when you brought the prisoners
see that seems like the black girl me I
was in the 400s what the [ __ ] okay now
there we go there we go who thought I
would [ __ ] out there for a second oh she
can teleport fantastic why don't you
sign more often Clemmy you can't be
smoking back here Vince come on don't
give me that if bill smells a whiff of
smoke back here he'll flip what are you
thinking you know what I'm just gonna
tell him I'm not letting someone else
get blamed for this that's [ __ ] oh
it's Vince so it is for in two days come
on chance that's cool
so that son of a [ __ ] was lying ha ha
ha that's awesome that's really cool now
I like the DLC more you get them I'm so
slow at figuring these things out holy
[ __ ] I think the door is ringing sorry
ok we're back we best get in bed Troy
will be back any minute
well
I got him got him what's the difference
we do you everybody stay where you are
no need drawn suspicion that was so cool
Thank You Clem I told you you probably
wouldn't die nice job
oh thanks appreciate it it was nothing
sure it was anyway get some rest
it's my jacket gives me superpowers
I thought about duck today not his dumb
little face first things that come to
mind her always the dumb things he was
doing it kid was always running in
circles every damn place he went he just
run he couldn't stop him makes it harder
to remember he was a good boy well long
day tomorrow one long day so depressing
to think about duck but he's right he
added really damned ugly face and ugly
face duck Lee face alright we're all
here someone's got to get the radio out
too Luke what's the problem we should
probably figure out who's doing what
before we
time to get up
daylight's burnin they let you sleep in
All Things Considered
where's my dad he's where the rest of
you are going to work Rebecca
Nick Sarah Jane if you gotta take a piss
do it now the next break won't be for a
while Troy will be coming up for the
rest of you watches them like I said
Troy's coming for the rest of you the
[ __ ] does that mean she can easily hide
the walkie in your jacket right look if
we're gonna do something we have to do
it now and if Luke's all we got and we
pair up with him I can do it where's the
meeting Mike yeah
Clementine should do it are you [ __ ]
kidding yeah what the [ __ ] it's always
Clementine doing all their dirty whites
but come on that's crazy
yeah [ __ ] why would there's a million
reasons she knows Luke she can hide she
got the damn radio for us in the first
place who cares I'm sorry Mike
but I don't know you from [ __ ] Adam
all right and if I'm trusting someone to
do something this important I'm trusting
her why can't you do it Kenny the same
reason Mike shouldn't do it they'll
notice give me the radio all right
little chickens let's get to pecking all
right
I don't think today's gonna be like
yesterday no way
no shenanigans this roosters gonna be
surveilling your ass every second of the
day you here got that I'm afraid I need
an answer girl
yes sir come on oh you have your pockets
all out I'm sorry but it's the only way
to forget your tags I'll snagged on
something uh ah corn go [ __ ] so [ __ ]
okay
hey she's with me
oh [ __ ] I almost forgot yeah
well Tiger Dan oh geez wait wait what's
going on never mind just chores of a
different sort
come on city mouse can't you cut her a
break
she'd really rather keep with us people
she knows what what are we doing don't
worry about it come on
hmm I guess we don't really have a
choice this place is pretty [ __ ] big
I just wanted to make sure you were all
right oh so she cares I didn't believe
you when you told me about Reggie I ran
and found Bill once I left you figured
even if he had done it he'd make up some
sort of excuse but bill was just so
matter-of-fact about it like he'd pulled
up a weed or something yeah it had to be
done and that was just one of those
moments when your blood runs cold goose
pimples up and down your arm goose
pimple turns out the person you thought
you knew was never there
it's disgusting way to put it you look
anxious Clementine something the matter
what do you think
after a [ __ ] story like that anyway
she's covering the walkie I know but
still you know you can talk to me right
no I don't trust her was dishonest when
I first met you but I swear on
everything holy that'll never happen
again
I I need to talk to Kenny do you now no
I can understand you're uncomfortable I
won't force you to be around me if you
didn't want to go on back out be with
Kenny
oh god that's awkward I just don't
[ __ ] trust her she'd betrayed us
before and I bet she will do it again if
she have to you know she's fun a gun
trust before because she had to and she
will betray us again if she has to
I'm sure she's nice but I don't [ __ ]
trust that [ __ ] okay I don't want to be
nice and then hurry that [ __ ] up
I hate babysitting you [ __ ] you rat
holes
Luke Luke are you okay
where the [ __ ] is he
oops we got anisette sodium put a little
bita little I'm sorry hope you enjoyed
watching leave a like a bit I really
appreciate an anime explain it hard it's
true try it
Oh what it's working no stop too much
care back anyway it's this car home
birthday I see you brothers tomorrow
love you guys